tom clancy the division two after more
than three years tom clancy's division
two is still releasing new content and
we have exciting times ahead to recap
season nine hidden alias produced so
much more than just a continuation of
the story we introduced countdown an
all-new eight-player pve and game mode
plus the brand new progression feature
expertise giving you new ways to
progress your agent and further increase
build variety and viability
and it's not over the division 2 is
scheduled to receive two more major
updates this year season 10 and season
11.
you will be able to enjoy season 10
price power in just a few days
it will introduce additional difficulty
modes for countdown to push your squad
to the limit add an array of
long-awaited quality of life changes and
set you on the path to uncover the
growing aliens between natalya sokolova
and general anderson and when it comes
to ensuring your agent looks the best
for the new manhunt we've got you
covered
shape paragon and dark path april events
are packed with a variety of new outfits
and vanity to give your agent a unique
look to close out 2022 for the division
2 season 11 will continue the division
story not only introducing new manhunt
targets but also some familiar faces and
a new ally it will also feature a brand
new pve mode expanding the variety of
activities and playability in the game
we'll share more details about all these
features later this year
now we want to retariate our commitment
to the long-term future of the division
2
which is fully supported by our talented
developers from ubisoft teams across the
globe with this in mind we're happy to
announce that we are committed to and
have started working on the division
year five
the future is pride for the division two
and for the division franchise as a
whole
now i'll hand over to kerry to introduce
you to tom clancy the divisions
heartland
over the last few years the team at red
storm entertainment has been hard at
work creating an all new experience set
in the world of the division
you've already rebuilt operations in
manhattan
you've responded to the call in
washington dc and now you're needed in
the small town of silver creek right in
the heartland of america
today we're excited to share a first
look at the game and some updates from
our studio here's our creative director
keith evans to tell you a little bit on
what to expect in the division heartland
hey everyone we're so excited to show
you heartland an all new standalone
adventure in the division universe
the teams poured their heart into this
game and we can't wait to share with you
welcome to silver creek
[Music]
i'm keith evans creative director in
heartland at redstorm entertainment
we've been involved here at redstorm
with the division going back before the
first game launched our partnership with
massive entertainment made some games
that we love we're so excited to bring
something new to fans of the franchise
heartland's a free-to-play survival
action shooter set in the division
universe that features streamlined
survival gameplay and a beautiful new
world to explore
you play as a division agent given the
task of protecting silver creek a small
town in middle america from enemy
factions rogue agents and a deadly
contamination this game ties directly
into the timeline and introduces all new
characters and story lines to the
franchise
heartland feels fresh and distinct while
still feeling at home alongside the
other amazing games in this universe
we can't wait to have you join us in
silver creek
follow the official division social
channels to learn more about the journey
the team has taken and the important
role of player feedback in the evolution
of the heartland experience and register
now for upcoming tests at
thedivisionheartland.com
finally a few weeks ago we welcomed a
new entrance in the division franchise
on mobile the division resurgence this
new opus brings the acclaimed aaa
experience to mobile with the addition
of a new story line factions and much
more the team is hard at work preparing
what comes next so it is our great
pleasure to be able to give you an
update on the game we wanted to take a
moment to thank everyone who has
participated in the closed alpha playing
solo or cooperating with others to
complete a taste of the game's unique
campaign and open world activities your
feedback has been priceless as we keep
fine tuning and improving the game today
we're happy to announce that a closed
beta test is coming this fall
this will be an opportunity to play the
iconic conflict pvp modes and for the
first time on mobile the dark zone
we leave you with a look at the trailer
let's go
oh
you